comme vous pouvez le voir j'ai baissé
les coûts d'exploitation du coup malgré
la crise nous avons atteint les
objectifs fixés
à partir du mois prochain chaque berline
sera payée 2 centimes demande à
varades vos revendications sont justes
et la justice ne se demande pas elle
s'impose
les mineurs souhaitant d'autres des
centaines de toute la région
seul un idiot quitte la partie avant
d'encaisser ces gars
on a fait tous ces sacrifices pour rien
moi jusqu'au bout parce qu'on n'a plus
rien à perdre juriste et la carte
rappelle la voilà la guerre la voilà
la seule solution pour que les patrons
ne respecte c'est l'union des mineurs
alors maintenant vous avez le choix soit
vous êtes avec nous soit vous êtes avec
les patrons des médias pas d'entre deux
[Applaudissements]